[Music]
is the hijab 10
discount code for 10 percent discount on
a wide range of products including
premium ethiopian black seed products
assalamu alaikum
i am going to respond to a video that
has gone semi viral you could actually
say it's gone viral depending on your
definition of course
a woman a broadcaster from india who has
perpetuated falsehood really monstrous
falsehoods one after the other blunders
she's made blunders mistakes speaking
with authority where she shouldn't have
done so
and i'm gonna be reacting to this video
of this woman speaking about the
afghanistan situation about the taliban
about the sharia law in fact the video
is entitled what is the sharia law so
that's a cess
in watching this video whether this
woman understands that which she's
talking about
there was a time when afghanistan was a
modern state faith was a private matter
so already we're talking about modernity
right so there's an assumption from the
very outset that western modernity
progressivism in that sense
is potentially the barometer or the
standard
that we should meet well these
assertions or these assumptions
have to be evidence in and of themselves
we don't need to
go towards modernity or progressivism or
western culture
and if you do if you do want to put us
in that kind of category of going
towards this and you think that's the
right thing to do then you have to argue
for that from first principles it's not
good enough to just say well it's
modernity and assume it you have to
argue from the beginning and i come to
you with arguably the most controversial
concept in the world
it's arguably the most controversial
concept in the world of course it's not
maybe befitting for me to to outline the
fact that controversiality does not
equate to falsity and i'm not saying
that she's saying that but just to make
sure that our audience or the end user
here is fully familiar with this point
but is it the most controversial thing
in the world
i mean
there are lots of things historically
and contemporaneously that have been
more controversial the shape of the
earth has been extremely controversial
on the history of cosmology in the last
thousand years
even more controversial you could argue
a sati
a practice called sati
that was done by hindu women
historically and even up until the
modern age actually and this practice
what involved a woman burning herself
in mourning
for her husband's death
talk about women's rights so one of
those things it took the colonial powers
the british powers to come and outlaw
this thing the white man to come and
tell you what was right and wrong
yes no wonder why you're so obsessed
with the white man because he stops you
from burning yourselves i mean i
understand the inferiority complex here
but
let's not try and think now that
this is the once again the barometer
that we must all fulfill or the
um
the the standard that we must all meet
the white man standard why is it so
controversial why does the world fear it
will take afghanistan further back in
time
what do you mean by the world do you
mean the white man
is that what we mean or the western
powers or colonial powers or ex-colonial
powers or the superpowers who do you
mean by
the world
okay let's keep listening we've spoken
to a lot of scholars and experts to put
this report together you've spoken to a
lot of scholars and experts so i'm
expecting what you say about sharia law
is going to be something which is
academically robust and if if not then
you will be
obviously to blame thanks to the
misrepresentation manipulation and
misuse of the sharia by whom islamic
regimes politicians clerics radicals
terrorists they've all used the sharia
to rule in the name of god
so coming back to the question what is
the sharia well there is no
that's not the exclusive property of
religious disciples
many radicals and terrorists have used
secular ideology to do the same thing so
this is not this is not an exclusivist
discourse here i mean we can we can
point to stalin we can point to even
lenin we can point to mao we can point
to many different people who had
materialist ideologies and who did the
same thing
so
this is not an exclusivist discourse and
you shouldn't make it seem as if it is
where do the rules come from three
sources the quran which is islam's holy
book the sunnah which is basically the
deeds of prophet muhammad and the hadees
the sayings of the prophet this is the
first major blunder it's actually a huge
blunder
it's the quran
the hadith which is the sunnah i don't
know why you've separated the two things
and then the third thing is ishmael
which is consensus and the fourth thing
is yes
and actually nezhamad dina tofi who is a
one of the specialists of the principles
of jurisprudence
he mentions 11 sources all together
including
so
the saying of the sahabi all the rulings
of those who came before us in terms of
the other uh legal systems of moses and
for example abraham and so on
which is the idea of the common interest
all of these things are also sources of
sharia
and this is the reductionist
understanding that has left a lot of
people like yourself
reducing the sharia to just one or two
sources
this is not the case and in fact you
haven't even represented it correctly
according to any school of thought shia
or sunnah this is completely false what
you've said there is wrong listen to me
carefully what you said there is wrong
because once again to reiterate the four
major
masada sharia if you like
or the the four major sources of sharia
are the quran as you've mentioned the
sunnah which is the hadith which itself
is subdivided into different types
authentic sahih yamatawa
hassan hasan
and these categorizations are known by
the people of hadith and then you have
ishmael which is the legal consensus
which is defined by or as
the
the consensus of the jurists in one
specific time in one specific issue in
one of
the issues of the uh islamic
law
this is ishmael and then you have chaos
which is legal analogy for example if
something is haram
in the quran but then there's something
which also has the same causative
reasoning they analogize onto it for
example
alcohol is haram or wine is haram let's
say they analogize on to that
that smoking weed is haram they smoking
anything that intoxic hallucinogens are
haram because it's
analogized onto and this is one of the
masada if you like one of the
sources of sharia but there are these
are the four main ones there are other
ones like masala
this is actually a source of sharia
masala is the common interest
a lot of people are asking why is it
that the taliban are
acting in a more pragmatic manner now
is because of this source see if you if
you knew these things then you'd know
how to operate and how to interact with
those who you disagree with you don't
even know the source of sharia ah
therefore your analysis is going to be
reductionist is going to be false and
it's going to be lacking where are the
scholars now that you said you they
don't even know the basis of
sharia
in islam
there's a range of other sources to work
out how god wants muslims to live but
there is no single law book no definite
statute no said judicial proceeding
that's false there is a set judicial
precedent it's not precedent it's
precedent and there is a there is a set
precedent from the ishmael
so when scholars make a decision on the
par or on the uh on whatever his issue
is they look at the ishmael if there's a
ishmael or a consensus of a past that
acts effectively like a judicial
president it's basically a vast
collection of different often
conflicting interpretations
these are that's not
see you're confusing it yourself you
said sharia is different because the
interpretations and sharia is god's will
now you're saying that sharia has got
sharia is diff different interpretations
which is false you can't even keep up
with your own script that you're reading
in front of your face
this is ignorance compounded
interpretations gave birth to five
schools of thought five legal schools of
sharia and you must know this there are
different kinds of sharia
we must know this and you're gonna teach
us you must know this
by the way there are more than four five
six seven schools of thought these are
the ones which have survived
there are many schools of thought atari
had a school of thought
had a school of thought these big names
had a school of thought they just
haven't survived so if you want to be
meticulous and you want to be precise
then don't speak in the way that you've
just spoken
these four belong to sunni islam the
fifth is a shia version of what about
what about the what about zaydi shias
you've completely missed a big chunks so
you're all over the place zaydi shia is
they are the majority of the yemeni
population of shiites you've completely
left them out in your analysis here how
comes
sharia it's called jafri
all five of them are named after
theologists and jurists the men who
theologians and jurists
yes
interpreted islamic texts
now look at this map
the hanbali school is the smallest and
strictest of them all it's primary
what you define as strict this is it
seems to be a very subjective reading
what do you define as a strict there's
many rulings in the hamburglar school of
thought
i'm not just saying that because
obviously i come from that school
thought but um there are many rulings
which are by and large more facilitative
for many different people so this is a
very
odd kind of subjective value judgment
coming from someone who has no knowledge
of any of the schools of thought and you
probably wouldn't ask you why is it the
strictest you probably wouldn't know how
to answer that
resource is the quran it is practiced in
saudi arabia and qatar
it also has significant followers in
these countries i mean saudi arabia yes
they practiced
a lot of a lot of people a lot of
jerusalem humbly there about a lot of
salafists who are not non-medhabi
actually in saudi arabia and so once
again the awam the the labe audience the
lay people this is very important for
even us to know as muslims there's a
difference between what the elitists or
the clerics or whatever it is they
practice and what the lay audience
their lay audience really doesn't have a
method
the ami doesn't really know about the
hamburglar school of if you ask him
what's the difference between himself
and hanafi they all know the difference
so this is only applicable really to the
elitists
but you wouldn't know that the shafi
school of sharia relies on consensus
over understanding of the quran i would
dare you i dare you to find me one book
from imam shafi's
the first book ever written
on usual by the way in islamic history
he is the one who which is islamic
jewish prudence are they to find me one
book of shafai usual which says that
consensus is
preferred over the quran there's no such
statement made by any scholar in islamic
history you've just made a fool of
yourself not realizing it speaking
nonchalantly and casually
this is embarrassing this is totally
embarrassing why are you speaking about
these matters
why are you speaking about these matters
you clearly are uneducated
you think you're educated you're
uneducated you're being educated right
now you've just made a huge blunder you
said the shafai school of thought relies
upon consensus over the understanding of
the quran and there is no such there is
not even one scholar in islamic history
from any school of thought who's ever
said such a thing you fool the hanafi
school the earliest the most flexible
version of the sharia it relies both on
consensus and independent reasoning the
hanafi school has the largest number
there's all of the schools of thor have
class except for the school of thought
so you're making as if this is a special
speciality of the hanafi method it's not
independent reasoning is ps which is
analyzing and then analogizing causative
reasoning and then and analyzing
backward formula this is not as special
as a speciality of the hanafi method all
of them if they have except for the
vladimir which he didn't mention
is uh in fact
has that has that future they live in
turkey jordan lebanon egypt afghanistan
pakistan india
yeah afghanistan so you've called it the
most flexible form of sharia
but but how do you square that with the
fact that the taliban are implementing
it you've you so you see there's
contradictory messaging here in your
broadcast you don't you don't even seem
to realize it that's how embarrassing it
is but the problem begins when religion
is mixed with governance
she says the problem begins when
religion is mixed with governance that's
that is a supposition you're making an
assertion you've gone from inform
informative broadcast to persuasive
broadcasting so now you're inserting a
secular ideal my question is the
presumption of secularity how can you
assert that without giving any evidence
what are your demonstrative proofs that
secularism is the neutral way or the
best way to live
do you have any evidence to in support
of secularism how do you even support
how do you even define secularism
because if secularism is a def is a
division between church and state
or religion and secular governance my
question to you is what constitutes his
religion if you look at the sociological
literature you'll find that there's
broad definitions which include
political ideologies things like
feminism things like liberalism and
things like ironically enough
constitutionalism republicanism
nationalism as well so if that is the
case
then to what extent can a government
like yours in india a nationalist
government a secular government one that
maybe claims to be liberal and democrat
democratic at the same time all those
things
could that be classified as a religious
type of reasoning or a religious kind of
thing in the first place and if it is
religion
then if it is religious then it wouldn't
be secular and so once again your ideal
would be dismissed why should we
prioritize even if barring
or bearing into consideration secularism
why why should we con why should we
privilege political ideology over and
above
theological
uh systems is there any argument that
you have from first principles that lead
us to that
so you see you see the problem is you've
inserted your opinion
my dear and unfortunately what you
haven't done is provide any evidence and
the quran states
bring your evidences for your truthful
many muslims who embrace the sharia
thought of it as a substitute for the
law of the land and that's where the
problem lies the sharia was just
supposed to be a way of living so now
you're making a theological claim you're
saying it's meant to be a way of living
it's not meant to be for governance
so but how would you make sense of all
the quranic verses in that hadith which
clearly indicates
that
which are addressing in the first place
politicians
generals and armies and so on and while
european nations later separated the
church from the state many islamic
countries did not
france britain and other europe so
so uh
european powers had colonized much of
west asia africa and asia when they left
leaders of the newly formed muslim
majority countries faced a dilemma
should they govern based on previous
islamic values or should they embrace
laws inherited leaders of those nations
that you're talking about were usually
puppet leaders installed by the colonial
overlords that just left well they chose
the sharia as the basis of their legal
justice system well you said it yourself
they chose if if that is what you
believe that they chose and the people
of the country chose that and we say 96
according to pew of afghani people want
the sharia isn't that a kind of
democratic reasoning
and if it is a kind of democratic
reasoning on your worldview shouldn't
you be respectful
respectful of that and get out of their
business what's your point why are you
getting involved in other people's
choices you said they chose the sharia
so what why is it what's got to do with
you as an indian what happens in
afghanistan iran or anywhere else
you're it's island of your business with
what you respect you should focus on the
minorities in india that are being
destroyed killed and lynched
if you want to talk about
rights human rights what makes this law
acceptable in some countries and
horrific in others
it's understanding and implementation
some countries enforce the most
discriminatory and patriarchal right so
what does so if that's true what would
make it different from any other system
and now you've mentioned a key term
what if i reject the term altogether as
a social construct because actually if
we say for example that patriarchy talks
about oppression of men to women
then there's a whole range of backlash
literature now in the west even that
actually calls into question that very
notion warfarin himself talks in the
myth of male power about the fact that
if you define power as somebody's
ability to have control of their own
life then you can't say that men being
forced to go to war and go into
dangerous jobs and so on and so forth
that counts as power and so your idea of
patriarchy therefore will completely
change forget about okay backlash
literature even third wave feminists
people like judith butler in her book
gender troubles she puts into the
question this notion of patriarchy so
why should we assume patriarchy once
again you're assuming all these labels
patriarchy modernity progressivism
without arguing them for them first on
first principles why should we be
colonized mentally and ideologically as
you and i in our respective nations were
colonized physically by the british
troops
why are you submitting
in this manner
why is there some kind of inferiority
complex perhaps that you have
are you weakened by
western hegemony have you got nothing to
offer or have you got nothing that
you've extracted from your own culture
that can compete with western
ideological hegemony
and is that the reason why you have such
an inferiority complex we don't feel the
same way unfortunately and you know the
thing is you and i both know the reason
why you're speaking about islam and
they're all scared of it is because it's
a sleeping giant that you don't want to
wake up because it's the thing that for
hundreds of years civilization lee had
brought all of these different nations
together
multicultural multiracial
and also multi-religious
under one banner
and it's the thing you're you're scared
of which is why in your country your
political leadership is doing what it's
doing to the minorities there don't
pretend we know why you keep mentioning
muslims in your streams and islam
because you're scared of it you're
coward they selectively picked certain
verses from the quran and legalized
draconian practices
like polygamy
how is polygamy a draconian practice you
seem not to even understand the words
that you're using polygamy by the way is
something which is sanctionable by
liberalism there's nothing wrong with
polygamy or liberalism tell me one thing
that liberalism opposes about polygamy
by the way hinduism which is probably
the religion of your forefathers and
predecessors i don't know if it's your
religion as well but certainly it's the
majority of religion in india allows
polygamy let's take a look at what zakir
naik the guy by the way you tried to
kick out of your country because he was
converting the people to islam
yes and because of free speech let's see
what he has to say about this matter if
you read ramayan the father of ram king
dashrath he had three wives
if you read the vishnu sutra chapter
number 24 verse number one it says a
brahman can have four wives
if read ma bharat krishna and how many
wives four
ten thousand ten thousand krishna had
sixteen thousand one hundred and eight
wives he didn't like hearing his voice
did you
made him made you angry didn't he like
many of the hindus nationalist hindu
nationalist racist i know how you feel
about that man
but you can die in your age with all due
respect you can die in your rage
because he still
has changed the demographic of your
country genital mutation
genital mutation
you can't even say the word dear you
can't even say the word it's mutilation
mutation what is this kind of what is
this transformers what is a cancer
you can't even speak english properly
can you it's mutilation and you're
saying this is meant in the quran
and then
underneath is not mentioned in the quran
in any quranic verse
so why i mention it in the list with
with with polygyny it should be
pollution why polligenic and mutilation
why are you putting them together and by
the way triple talaq
i mean uh doing through talking one much
less is haram something that islam
doesn't allow according to all schools
of thought does god judge differently
based on gender no the quran actually
answers that directly itself
that god does not let to waste
any deed of those who do deeds from men
and women and both of them are from one
another why are you mentioning this as
if it's something that we believe in
what who are you even uh
putting this to
you know the answer if if you're asking
a theological question the quran says no
for many clerics it does it shouldn't do
because the quran i don't know of any
cleric scholar islam who believes that
give me one name of a scholar who
believes that there is not such a thing
as spiritual equality in islam we do not
believe that equality in value means
identicality and roles so where there is
physiological or
psychological whatever it may be
differences between men and women there
may be some
facilitation for either man and or woman
in the quran
but we would say that is fully justified
why should man and woman dress
differently in fact you're talking about
dress code if i were to take my shirt
off and a woman was to take her shirt
off in this very country that i live in
the uk yeah do you think will be judged
the same even by the law in this land no
the answer is not despite the fact that
women worked and fought alongside the
prophet
they won't tell you this
in some countries who won't tell you
this women cannot step out without an
abaya or a veil but men can dress the
way they want really can men dress the
way they want or is there not a
restriction for them from the navel to
the knee as well
once again you don't know sharia and you
don't know if so you're making blunders
women cannot stand for president but men
can govern for a lifetime who said women
cannot stand for president in islam who
said this
this is a different a matter of opinion
you mentioned this already there's a
difference between khalifa
okay and wizard
and it's not it's no consensus in islam
that a woman cannot stand for a
president or if a leader of a country
there's no consensus on to that
to that effect women cannot choose to
have an abortion
women can choose to have an abortion
before 40 days according to the hambuli
medhab if there is a reason for it but
abortion is not a muslim specific issue
i don't know why you're mentioning it
in fact islam has a more lenient view on
abortion than catholicism
why are you mentioning abortion anyway
after a certain time period many people
would say when the baby becomes viable
or insolvent happens then no we
shouldn't cause an abortion because we
are not going to
prefer so-called women's rights on
children's rights
so what are you talking about
why why are you now inserting abortion
into this discussion you seem to be
secularizing the discourse even to the
even to the detriment of the uh
the american discussion on abortion this
is a discussion that's happening in
america whether abortion is okay or not
but men are allowed to have four wives
so what if men are allowed to have four
wives what's wrong with that
why shouldn't men have four wives in in
this country in the uk i can have a
thousand women sexual partners one
thousand just like krishna had sixteen
thousand one hundred and eight wives so
when krishna can have sixteen thousand
one and eight five so why can't we
muslims have at least
four women cannot travel without a male
guardian why would they want to travel
in a country like india without a male
guardian their male guardians are being
lynched themselves why would a woman
want to risk it and get raped
try women cannot retain
where does it say women cannot drive in
the islam and in fact i don't think any
country now the last one was saudi
arabia that that's implementing that
they've stopped implementing that and
even their foreign minister by the way
has said that this is a cultural
practice of ours has got nothing to do
with islam
so why are you mentioning that as if
it's got something to do is this
something that was even practiced in
afghanistan that women can't drive is
this something that was practiced in
india or pakistan or egypt or indonesia
so what's the proportion my question is
now you're talking about demography
saudi arabia was the only country which
banned 30 million people was 1.8 billion
so why are you generalizing some such a
small country in terms of population to
the entire muslim community in the world
1.8 billion people
it seems to me like you're really
clutching at straws here and it seems to
me like you're embarrassing yourself by
using all these kind of orientalist
tropes and
kind of generalizing the discourse with
it how embarrassing
they have their children after divorce
and that's that's actually false you
should you said that women don't have
custody of the children of the
i don't know who who you got that from
in fact women do have custody over their
children of a divorce and in fact to the
detriment of the man in most cases
unless she gets uh divorced and so on i
sort of get remarried again and there's
discussions about how that takes place
but what you're saying is false women do
get custody of their children after
divorce and there's that hadith in
timothy to that effect where a woman
came to the prophet and said i have
raised the child and i've read thing
i have uh gave it for my put on my lap
and given it my milk and so on and the
prophet said that you
would be given custody of it but if you
get married that the custody will be
given to the man
and so the jurors differ as to how this
would take place but your what you're
saying is false
in fact custody laws are bolstered for
women in islam
and in fact there are so many things
that i could even speak about in regards
to breastfeeding and how breastfeeding
can some schools have thought say the
man has to pay for it the hamburglar
school of thought which you said was
more strict says you have to pay for the
breast milk and so
so you seem to me
as an ignorant person who doesn't know
about sharia and is conflating between
cultural practices
and the sharia receive half of what is
awarded to their brothers in inheritance
yes but they also receive the same if
they're a man if sorry they're the same
if they're a parent and they receive the
the lion's share if there's two sisters
if there's more than two women they get
two thirds of what's left behind it's a
misconception to assume therefore that
women inheritance get less than men in
islam all things including religion must
evolve with time
okay that's an assertion if that's what
you think everything including religion
must evolve with time what is your
evidence for that and what is it
evolving towards is it evolving towards
western enlightenment value and what
makes western and life and value true
you have to be able to argue from first
principles that liberalism is true that
secularism is true that any ism that you
decide to pluck out from them post
enlightenment or enlightenment discourse
is true in the first place before you
say evolution because this implies
progression
if some practices are outdated they must
end
well what about democracy it's the most
outdated practice known to
western western ideology it's a three
thousand year old it's a two thousand
year old practice two two and a half
thousand year old practice yet we still
practice it in one form or another so
this is the genetic fallacy you are
saying because of when something uh
existed it must end
what if something is true
what if it happened a thousand years ago
but it's true maria's interpretation and
practice clashes with today's way of
life
what's today's way of life what the
white man said is that what you mean by
what the white man said what the
privileged white colonial white man said
social structures then perhaps it's time
for revision and reflection
and perhaps not rather than resentment
so as we've seen here this is
misinformation lack of argument proper
argumentation if her argument
was of building
okay
the foundations would now
would be crumbled at the edifice
the building would be blown to bits
and would be a pile
or a heap of rubble
next time when you try and speak about
islam
get your facts right
or get ready to be embarrassed as you
have been in this session
assalamu alaikum
foreign